the proclamation of the accession
whereas it has pleased almighty God to
call to his Mercy our late Sovereign
Queen Elizabeth II of blessed and
glorious memory by whose deceased the
crown of the United Kingdom of Great
Britain and Northern Ireland is solely
and rightfully come to Prince Charles
Philip Arthur George
we therefore the Lord's spiritual and
temporal of this realm and members of
the House of Commons together with other
members of her late Magistas privy
Council and representatives of the
rounds and territories aldermen and
citizens of London and others do now
hereby with one voice and consent of
tongue and heart publish and Proclaim
that the Prince Charles Philip Arthur
George Is Now by The Death of our late
Sovereign of happy memory become our
only lawful and rightful lead Lord
Charles III by grace of God of the
United Kingdom of Great Britain and
Northern Ireland and of his other Realms
and territories King head of the
Commonwealth defender of the faith to
whom we do acknowledge all faith and
obedience with humble affection this
seek teaching God by whom kings and
queens do Reign to bless His Majesty
with long and happy years to Reign Over
Us
given this day of the tenth day of
September and that your hero Lord 222.
God Save the King
the king